we begin with developing news out of  Ukraine where a helicopter crashed near  the capital of Kiev has claimed the  lives of more than a dozen people  officials initially said 18 people were  killed in the crash however the death  toll has since been lowered to 15 among  the victims Ukraine's interior Minister  as well as at least two children the  chief of Ukraine's National Police says  at least 29 people were also injured  that the helicopter belonged to the  country's State emergency service the  governor of the key region says the  helicopter crashed near a kindergarten  and a residential building the cause of  the crash at this point remains unclear  this comes just four days after a  Russian missile struck an apartment  building in Ukraine's fourth largest  city in nepro killing at least 45  civilians and leaving hundreds of people  without a home at this point  um  foreign  foreign